right whoa that's good timing hello to
people let's play chess my opponent has
high lag thought usually this means
they're offline
maybe my opponents just preparing for me
hello to everyone a Capac first in the
chat move was second online school rocks
okay let's let's say folks focus on the
chess all sigh oh say hi to people in
the chat probably after this game yeah
I'm just gonna play a traditional London
some kind of main line here knight c6
I'll play Bishop b5 Aakash
thanks for the hosts yeah this is all
mean line that you 753 this is kind of
an improved version of this Bishop d3
line now the fives a move I should
really check this line 5 sliding new
move I am hey hey the wizard is back
long time no see it's been like maybe a
week or two I hope you're doing well
before before is like the move that
usually want to play in these positions
yeah it actually looks reasonable hit
the night trying trying to provoke a
knight takes g3 or Bishop takes g3
hitting the bishop here - there's some
line takes takes I hit the rook rook e8
then I take the pawn bishop spin to the
rook if takes and I can probably
queenside castle use a D file
and in any line with this or this and I
take and there's there's some pressure
against h7 I forgot this night moves
backwards we should be sevens probably
very playable then so I could probably
take take twice probably to take once
and then take on c5 and then rook t1 or
queenside castling probably rook t1 just
a lining threatening the stuff or takes
and then Bishop takes h7 I'm not
entirely sure if Locke does here is yeah
I just take the night and then tactics
okay
that was nice 16 move win with the
london night of 5 I know is playable
actually the the very first video in my
London course covers this line I show a
magnus carlsen game Charleston played
played this exact specific
and his opponent played b6 and he won he
got a winning position within like six
or seven more moves maybe six wasn't
that very strongly with with e4 anyway
hello to everyone
Victor's neighbor saying thank you for
the games last week my username comes
from living in the same neighborhood in
Berlin as Kurtz Richter huh I'm from
Sweden though interesting I don't know
who Kurt Richter is Alexa who's Kurt
Richter Richter was an Austrian art
director of the silent era he designed
the sets for more than a hundred films
during his career including a number
made by the leading German company who
fought where he frequently collaborated
with director Ernst Lubitsch okay so I
guess that's what you'll be known by
it's factors neighbor it's also Sweden
is a nice country I've never been to
Berlin but I've been to Sweden isn't
Sweden for like one hour so it was not a
five a good mover that's a good question
I think it's better it's interesting
this move is is recommended in Avex
one of our X like repertoire books I
think is D for sidelines book from
blocks perspective I don't think this is
a great move I think the the most
theoretical move here is Bishop e7 which
is kind of hard to explain but it deals
with the threats White has a positional
threat here of takes takes Queen a4 and
then eventually to takes and Queen a3
and do stuff so the vision e7 prevents
all of that and then it kind of sets up
this knight h5 idea to to get the bishop
here there's other lines relaxed this is
a very playable move to the 97 sacrifice
87
did I win yeah I won in 16 moves I know
a lot of people are joining after the
game completed but yeah the whole idea
here is that Bishop d3 is a move in this
position but well we did in the game was
this is this so I basically played
Bishop d3 and played 97 so I improved
one of my pieces and and just some dis
improved unimproved the Knights for
black now block tried to justify it
Victor's neighbors saying Kurt Richter
Oh Kurt Richter the chess player Oh
Richter rouser ah yes I'd never realized
that Richter rouser it was named after
someone named Ricker Richter and maybe
he's also someone named rouser
Liz Richter browser is that is that two
different people or is that the same
person with two last names so there's
also Richter veresov hmm names are
confusing to different people
okay Neal welcome back how's it going
Neal can you explain ideas in Cuba
what's qid Oh Queens Indian defense well
let me let me first explain this London
London and stuff because all the line I
show in my course involves b6 I think I
do cover I cover a comp ski game also in
like Horace it was calm ski versus
roofing Lee Roofing play tonight g6 and
comp ski cot like a very amazing like
King side attack that 95 and pushing H
pawn but after v6 it's a really amazing
line Oh which I can't show so check out
my London course London command it's
also the first like one hour is free on
YouTube anyway ok let's start
oh I'm playing a strong player wing
Zubov Zubov played maybe one tournaments
where Zubov played in Spain everyone
plays Bishop a4 these days yeah I'm not
so well booked up but let's try my best
should Bishop e7 makes sense I just kind
of play this position on feel and now I
just don't know what to do maybe a 6 C 5
is also a move wait did I have that name
I maybe had this position in Canada not
too long ago maybe c5
I really don't know here there's also
just a six dealing with an IP five stuff
I'm gonna try and continue developing
say with pong I took with night I with a
velocity 797 recognized f/8 um still
have to be a little bit conscious of c7
it is tender but the night is blocking
the tack I'm probably gonna suffer here
a little bit maybe I should have played
the Queen's Indian avoid with all of
this all right there's c5 here you can
see 5s probably the go-to move Oh some
idea c4 earlier 94 later b5 I'm getting
kind of a typical in Queens gambit
declined structure that's why for I want
to start with rook c8 just leave the
tension there's [ __ ] about five though
Bishop a5 rook c7 is probably okay I
could have started with 94 as well what
does this do l1 I don't know but you did
it
thanks for subbing should H four okay
Queen b6 here
trying to pressure this pawn even though
the pawns defended by tactics because
takes takes takes and then digit takes
h7
but maybe I can play 96 ideas here let's
start with rook t8 defending this pawn
oh this is maybe coming takes I guess
there's ninety four in that line with
Queen e7 so take six ninety four is a
move because discovery the queen e7 not
dead yet hmm you have to do something
here though I don't want to play this
move but okay at least I have a plan as
long as I don't get needed which this is
getting very scary in g6 probably makes
some sense
oh they can also maybe take well it's
kind of cool
by soccer rook No
I'll make that work oh the rucksack oh
yeah it doesn't quite work unfortunately
a g6 Bishop g7 if I have time after the
game I was analyzing takes twice on e5
and then these ideas seem to - crazy
maybe some ethics idea mm-hmm I'm
getting squeezed I don't like this make
six hates maybe now start with the
smooth I'm very seriously considering
just taking twice let's do it it doesn't
work though my time - mm-hmm
they see three it's kind of a panic move
wasted too much time there
some Queenie six idea come to h3 should
be six the bishop fighting vision of
each three now this is bad how my rook
is hanging - that was really bad
lean down how many pawns down so many
pawns down to pawns behind getting
forked never resigned when you have a
knight jacking this and this defends
okay my only hope is to fork somehow oh
that's a good move as if I move either
away I I get pinned I resigned that was
rough oh good game though was
interesting a pony could have put me
away much quicker
by winning this rook I should have I had
to take care with Chuck first I probably
should have cut Queens on the board but
it's already like everything's falling
apart cuz the Queen's attacked the pawns
attacked and then f6 is like once Knight
takes d5 f6 and the rock are our hits
yeah the final position was lost maybe I
could pick up the rook but no I can't
because he takes with the rook takes
with Bishop if everything is losing for
me
playing my in the position from the
opening this is reasonable live analysis
so what I want I was looking at Tom a
crazy line where was it even back here
after g5i I really wanted to take and
then take care and then take care and
the threat is d4 and I get some it looks
really strong maybe I should have done
this I rejected it because Queen f3
Queen f3 is probably good enough fair
for white design of t4 I lose a bishop I
could take and do this but there's busy
before that's Scott sacked before he
played King G - Kim G - oh so like right
here yeah the problem is sacking I lose
a whole rook and then oh the d4 hits
this row actually the problem was
stacking yours Queen takes f7 and then
it's not gonna end well
probably Queen takes f7 rook c7 and just
getting crushed so I can I can ask the
engine like if I had anything better you
can round here with a couple moments
probably should have dealt with this
pawn storm
okay so computer doesn't mind this
suggesting Bishop takes e5 rook d7 okay
can't analyze too much I have to analyze
later let's play another London worked
while the first game playing Popo
something something okay so King's India
maybe heard this line they design last
week against Hans niemand Hans castled
h5 also is a playable move here I'll
play Knights 95 is playable I think I'm
supposed to take actually I'll admit I'm
not like this is another opening I
probably have to review some like Queen
d4 idea maybe the Queen d4 here then 95
than before there's my ft-7 it's still
before might be going a little bit too
insane here I'm just curious how black
deals with his threat and 24 it's a very
greedy move trying to cover everything
d5 is also a bit tender in these
positions so I can play d4 and then take
I could be up to pawns I have had zero
bananas today I have had my lion brain
juice yeah this says shake more than you
think okay I also have to think so yeah
there's a smooth ah so opponent might
play Queen c7 which honestly I forgot
about the Queen c7 I just take on d5
yeah and curious there's Quinta three oh
there's that move but I can take wait
I'm confused
I'm just gonna be other piece in the
slide yeah I'm up a piece because one
two three one two my counting is is
correct it's been so long since I've
learned how to count
sounds like the preschool days but now
it to do I'm so flustered not used to
being up a piece on move thirteen I can
take a pawn but then Knight takes d4
you're probably not a bad idea to like
queenside castle the king is safe the
pawns defended this pond is still
attacked if he's six maybe at some point
a six
3/6 I mean the dark spheres are very
weak like the piece that black is
missing as a dark tread bishop so dark
squares all over the board it was a
London link broken got a message few
days ago that was broken but I tried it
last night and it was okay test later
okay if Knight takes d5 yeah I'll stay
focused here I can just trade bishops
probably okay well they take on d5 and
then work d8 let's do this
also the idea is if takes I take here
and then take on d5 I take on a five and
then I'm take on d5 take with the rook
as well yeah we'll take with a row
thanks for the bits oxygen gambit pawns
are shaped like the yeah pawns are our
social distancing just like the USA kind
of at least some parts of the USA I'm
gonna take on f5 but okay let's do this
have so many double isolated pawns
that's insane okay idea this
so we trade we trade some more some idea
is I'm losing h4 and then but I have a
six and then I break through yeah so it
takes and then a six and then then I
can't stop the pond I can come back here
but I take in them Queen I feel like all
my shaking from earlier didn't matter
because I let I let it settle
anyway okay that was a nice game a few
nights London games
this game was twenty-two moves my first
game was was sixteen moves yeah my point
yeah probably 9 ft 7 is wrong not sure
what my point was supposed to do
Oh was it actually maybe it was shaped
like actual country like because this is
the west coast this is the East Coast
this is Florida a Florida should really
be down here this is Canada okay yeah
let's just take a quick look Queen D for
blunder because Nike oh my G for I
wasn't my G for work
thank you for B for Queen a3 Wow stock
fish is so good I guess this pin is
really annoying the threat is to take
twice and then win before and then
everything crumbles like I would like to
play f3 and simplify rook b1 Nathan but
even knight c6 looks strong Oh takes
them and I see six I lose a piece ouch
so yeah something something terrible
could have happened well maybe I'm not
supposed to play 95 I got away with it
though
these align these positions are so
tricky it's so easy for your player just
to go wrong like this [ __ ] our Queen d2
Queen d2 break the pin understand digit
be six also this is very low depth so we
can always trust these evaluations my
drink looks magical
yeah I'm drinking I'm drinking glitter
but no I'm not actually drinking glitter
and drinking the ultimate super the
ultimate super herb elixir
it has mockery she might talk a turkey
tail lion's mane and ashwagandha well
can we get it if you want to close up
yeah I mean I could turn off the green
screen or the chroma key that's too
complicated blood of unicorn yeah yeah
the stalemate gave me some momentum but
also there is a game where I just down a
piece in some like King pawn ending I
was like bishop in pawns versus King in
pawns I I won with like a single oh I'm
playing a strong player I played
Bortnick before I know what he's gonna
play this King's Indian setup
he's also 29.99 oh wow so he plays up
here it's um
I'm putting I see three make it
interesting you play a dutch here i
guess
g6 yeah i think i'll just transpose into
whole i usually play like Queen d2 um
there's probably no need to include a
for ya just love black do what he wants
to do
Oh Sameach for move might sometimes
develop stage three and sometimes each
five can be played not also sometimes
develops here to defend the pond other
times this night comes back so it
depends each six interesting in tempted
to play a four and ninety-two 1c3 let's
try this
it was a typical idea to induce them to
move forward we might see c5 here c5 on
might be able to take it like I just
want to play c3 and trade off the pawns
and maybe the center will eventually
open up and now the bishop has a square
here which was another reason for a 4-2
to fight for this e4 square so c5
there's also the be five square but I
kind of like Bishop c4 here then 92 of
d1 the Knights it's kind of sad here
might do some maneuvering at some points
I should have considered taking maybe a
problem one comfort lack that I can't
like play Knight f6 and castle cuz the
rook is tied down to the pond so that
might benefit mean later where the King
might be stuck in the center let's play
ninety to defy might be coming and d5
Bishop e5 in 92
yeah I need Knight move I have Bishop
III 2097 to prepare you 5 I might be
threatening he five as well so some g4
move I'm just trying to be aware of my
resources hey it's been fine gold with a
giant raid thanks Ben and is providing
so many giant raids these days hope you
had a good stream I assumed you where
you're covering some some chess
tournaments more famous than the one I'm
currently playing in anyway if you're
just joining I'm playing chess and I'm
playing Bortnick who's strong player but
he's a long time should be three I'll
also be playing ban in a match in the
near future stay tuned for that
I think it's on May 4th od5 I should
stop talking should be five is a move it
should be 5 e 5 let's do this 56 yeah ok
I have to take and then probably 5 e 5 b
3 and some f4 and castling decent
position so there's also h 5 here if i
want to be extra spicy
should probably just connect the rooks
Oh
and King each one safe move
I'm really just putting the question to
black like what is black doing the night
probably wants to join back bring the
night to d3
so each fives a move eventually f4
especially if casting a playoff for do I
play it immediately in 93 first wow i
five a five is probably a good move
wants to close down the position if I
take I could take and if a knight takes
I've Knight c5 Bishop takes I playoff
for yeah I know I hit the pawn just
taking on g6 and then taking on g5 work
it's close I don't know what the other
doesn't not work Queen takes g7 might do
it anyway like 93 at four now it's
getting tricky
four takes enough I'm not if five
doesn't work now if I might be a decent
move anyway Queen takes h5 King here
3096
each fives a good move
I don't have the tactics mana tactics
oh no oh I'm getting meted oh look who's
game
I completely crocked and I'm pressure
yeah I was thinking about Queen and
Queen here Queen here and Bishop here
promise I get forts and then I like I
played King each one expecting Queen
I've to check but he played Queen I for
when I forgave me some chance like it's
a play bishops III Chuck or Queen e7
check as Queen I for was a good move his
efficacy 3a there's this move oh but
then 27 wins of Hong yeah King each one
was a bad anticipation was a nice game
though I mean I was definitely better
after I won the pawn this pun was a bit
weak though maybe I should've played g4
but if I played g4 here there's Queen e7
and Mike Bishop is is target in I'm
black calm well they're supposed to do
after after this
stockfish doesn't know I have to analyze
this in more depth later meantime I'll
take my anger out and chickens green
juice I allowed him to break 3000 oh wow
he did one point for beating me like
that
that's so probably so happy for him
so sad for me yeah stockfish doesn't
want to work that's okay the opening was
nice I like this a 4 and a 4 B 4 night a
2 C 3 ID then how many numbers do you
know I know a lot of numbers I don't
know if I know all the numbers so I'm 2
out of 4 I mean the two players are lost
to us to Zubov who's strong GN I mean
all the games at least my two losses
have been fights my two wins have been
quick quick London wins can you check
accuracy of your games on me chess I
could I could like copy like if I
download the PGN and then copy it to Ali
chess study but I'm not gonna do that
right now I'm curious like especially in
this final position computers are so
good at crunching through like the the
forcing lines anyway umm its refresh oh
the games are done so next game should
start any moment now
yeah thanks again Ben for the raid it
was a bit flustered it's such a big time
advantage to feel like there are some
moves my opponent was was close to
flagging this increment it's uh that's
tricky as you can't play to five
opponents just have to play good moves
O'Brien said that he thought I had
checked to win the night yeah I assumed
this move than Queen here almost works
but then there were counter tactics yeah
I was so difficult to play I wonder I'm
probably not losing my force here King H
yeah King H once so that I should like
eh - but then I'm losing a bishop so it
is probably just losing before this
position I assume here you're once
you're referring to earlier oh there's
some Queen c7 move for that and doesn't
seem like there's ever time for Queen c7
because I always have to take something
like my Knights attacks also this is
defended
and I have to take the road also the
Knights defended by the Queen so I'm
wondering why the next game isn't
starting because it's only round four
they usually take the break after around
seven doesn't appear like there's any
games happening a lot of people with
four out of four
sometimes will ha the people Wow
yes that's expected a 963 players
do I have a goal free donations or
something I want to get Oh dead man
Mandy I'm welcome back stopping for 21
months a long time son yeah if you're
just joining I am playing title Tuesday
here's an unexpected extended break
which I guess gives me more time to heat
the chat if you want to check the live
standings you have to go into live chess
go to tournaments and then look for I
don't know if you have to be in the
tournament to check the standing splits
now look for title Tuesday
the next match for the I am not a GM is
is tomorrow I'm playing one of the top
one of the top female players in Russia
I think she's number 13 in the world
among women ashley na or alina costing
skaia very strong player so it should be
an interesting match and there's three
okay let's play something solid tog II
welcome back
how's it going a tog II only joining
joining like five rounds in I should
take first okay b3 there's a few lines I
can play here I can play this I can play
c5 please let's play a5 a5 is
interesting line a3 as a3 makes sense
wondering if I can play like a 4 anyway
let's try it this might be dangerous
going out of any former study but maybe
thanks for all your content you're
helping me basically improve my chess
game that's nice to hear I don't know
what to do here and I should not be
thinking here either guess let's take if
takes probably c5 and I'll try and win
back the pawn eventually so my places
before actually now I can kind of play a
London setup like there's about five and
eighty Knight bd7 rook e8 oh I'll start
with this probably include age six
have to watch out for efore yeah thanks
for that
Jacob Marshall games appreciate the sub
I have this movie whoa it's double upon
gifting subs have to defend the pawn
thanks double the pawns I'll read off
the sub names maybe after this game but
I have to focus
already down about 30 seconds your
rookie coming yeah I need like simple
improving move I definitely want to play
quickly some Queen c7 Bishop h3 idea 95
the move at least I have a structure I
mean like decently comfortable with if
like goes for this e4 break I'll
probably just take and there should be 6
+ c4 would be weak as well as b3 we're
really taking time if maybe I have time
to read off the sub means mass around 0
1 Doug stone
mark Moscow 7 does this move so weird
move h6 birds by 10 and bwahahaha 9,000
thanks again double the pawns
let's move 95 26 so Queen is decent on
e6 if white ever play c4 there's 94
ideas let's trade Bishop wasn't wasn't
doing so much white space should not
doing so much either this Bishop doing
something so I didn't take maybe first
year the next year 96 ladies actually
decent on on the square
it's Queen a5 here Knights a bit lusty
son on the square I want to do something
against this thing you should know
vision needs to find a home let's start
with this
yeah the structure combined with this
night it's the pawns and night work
together to control squares potentially
both has gambit but probably not called
for
in the smooth a3s of the tender this
bishop is like my worst piece so we can
trade it that's a move probably have to
take yeah I would take 27 very
positional sinking my night is better on
g5 but maybe not I don't know
discouraging 95 just have to play
quickly your rookie six
there's 94 94 I retreats that's not a
bad move this maybe I can bring the
Knight to d6 actually am i coming to b5
is also a nice square and now that
Knights no longer pin because my bishop
defend this pawn b5 it's covered though
yeah so just by hitting upon mighty 94
Brooksie eights now it's probably
slightly better here it's gonna be a
fight
let's try this
time scramble time queeny's three ideas
you listen each for coming mm-hmm let's
try it
Queen a5 I'm either winning or losing or
drawing
[Music]
okay probably only run up with the King
G summons defended play this move there
we go
let's go is it winning though who's
better be winning wow what a game I'm
eatin em though there we go okay well
what a game this game I mean like we
both made extra Queens and we were both
on the verge of promoting like so many
different times I saw I'm probably just
losing hearing somehow I went down the
rook but it was tricky cuz their King
was loose
thanks for the bits hugging the women
bits and Serpine with the sub
yeah I was really kind of intense and
nerve-wracking I really don't know what
to make a vacuum yeah I could have
forced draw here I wanted to play for
more I mean this is all kind of
practical I really wanted to push the
pawn but my Queens always attacked yeah
things done man life is good not quite
100 moves but 95 moves in honor of of
Horatio 95 or 95 Horatio yeah also
doubled pawns gifted subs like ages ago
during that game which I think I read
off right oh yeah I did read off my
opponent took a long thing at some point
okay next game starts was not much of a
break but let's try and keep playing
chess playing the Vincent spit soul play
a London
I've had this position earlier
yeah p6 is a Lea trend year line these
days there's a basics okay so let's take
and probably 95 is Queenie - there's
some abyssion move I should know what to
do here complete there's a [ __ ] for now
block can't take because a light would
be pinned and attacked some idea in IG
for meanwhile dislikes was that is out
of play
there is vision e7 but the knight c6 c7
I'll the f4 it's like getting with
Stonewall setup I don't have my good
bishop but this is a decent Bishop again
there should be seven probably 96
I wanna bring the other night in and
there's g4g five ideas
there's Queen maneuvering ideas probably
makes sense to castle at some point -
meanwhile it's not so clear what black
should be doing so Bishop e7 okay so
this is on 98 2d sixes idea yeah I think
it makes sense to trade yeah I do trade
off my good Knights but maybe I'll have
another good night if the Queen never
moves away from defending the knight I
just take in double block spawns up and
there you hear that's very wise
yeah I don't know if I'm actually like I
felt like I was pushing for some
advantage but now it seems like luck is
untangling mmm okay I'll play 95 try and
keep attacking some f5 ideas it was very
typical Stonewall pawn break
one goal is to just keep applying
pressure to the night now Queen up three
may be recording off three there's
mighty - Quentin always swing over to h3
I want to play Brooke here
do you have to be careful of the fork so
maybe Queen each three and then rock up
on 87 while 97 we could train some c4
move actually taking and then c4 looks
quite strong there's a problem for black
as this pawn is tied down to the night
it's also attacked twice only defended
by the Queen if Knight d2 I think I just
take if Queen takes I take with pollen I
also take with rook but there is takes
and I'd see for coming there's also that
so I'm up a pawn it's gonna be some
weird endgame
he'll be b3e 396 ricky 5 you just want
to hold on to my my double D pawns
opponent abating I mean this is the most
logical square the problem in 96 is
Rocky five and I'm threatening to fork
the rook and Knight otherwise there's 93
but then this Holmes trying to calculate
G six while
well G 6 I have you work out 300 yeah
double the pawns cheering bits for my my
double ax pawns but they're there D pawn
zloty pawns so now the night is like
almost trapped so is 94 it's probably
rookie 3 eirick d8 is off-limits
sneaky Bishop rook e8 I have rook e1 and
the simple plan is just to promote the
pawn three moves away from from
womanhood it's hard to actually stop
there's no f6 also I might be
threatening this to track the Knights so
multiple ideas Oh Bach wants to play off
six but it doesn't work goes Ricky 7
also Bishop e7 could be played yeah like
there should be seven here and then I
just push the Knights out of play sounds
nice that's a good game I felt like I
was in control most of the game opponent
was trying to sort of like squirm yeah I
think c4 was was very explosive nice
little nice move that sometimes it's
easy to overlook because it's easy to
get content with keeping the structure
but yeah it's a box position was was
ready to crumble
okay yeah that was another another nice
London win gobble I've lost one game
with whites against bortnik a crazy game
but yeah a bunch of nice London wins
today yeah been Feingold we very much
approve of this I guess my opponent
didn't I never had the chance to play f6
and then but those idea at least of
kingi Saturn was to try and get in at
six
but then my point realized f6 runs into
rookie 7s when he tried to play g5 but
the bishop planted itself very nicely
okay planks from player whose's mr it's
ruined never heard of him good luck I'm
gonna see Queen f3 yeah everyone's
playing Queen are three of these is do I
play here I've played a lot of moves in
this position you'll play Knight of 6
and then let's align 95 and b5
there's some Fabiano cardiac in game
yeah it goes like this
no beef I think before strong here or as
it takes in then oh that's not a good
time to forget theory I think I'd have
to take on u3 and then play before I
played before right away yeah it doesn't
make any sense so let's do this
and it's a very sharp theory that it's
been a while since I've studied but okay
like whites also taking some risk here
before is a nice resource because if I
had to move the night then there's 94
and scary so with this probably just
takes in Bishop e7 exceeds mmm do stuff
I really can't complain about this I'm
probably Bishop c5 to come
there might be three probably visit East
seven and then like a five a four as a
main plan it looks like I wasted time
but whites and I got a bit misplaced and
whites probably gonna lose time soon
once a for happens so f5 f5 is very
aggressive I could take it I could just
ignore it that's ignorant
you just wanna pawn storm that goes back
so there's might be five ideas mission
t5 looks a bit logical here I think it's
just a nice square I didn't want to take
G to would have opened the file now this
move like Queen here coming
there's some III ideas as well as I have
the only dark square bishop so I do oh
wait but I did not mean to play there I
didn't even I didn't click and drag
oh but click click yeah I never figured
out how to turn off click click it's
really annoying now this is I mean at
least it's still playable orga fades I
just have to message one of the chests
icon people figure out if there's a way
to turn them off I haven't made one of
those slips in a while though because
there is a setting to choose between
click click and click and drag but when
you click click and drag it doesn't
disable click click okay let's focus
this is I can't take the night cuz
statics
[Music]
hmm
this is actually yeah it's not easy to
defend try this maybe three is a move it
was King like King d8 is also a decent
try getting off a light squares so
there's no no easy checks for whites
it's a very sneaky move that's a very
strong move maybe you work out for just
a lot of time ideas if takes I take the
night
we should curious what what's gonna do
here might have to go for this line but
that seems like a nice nice initiative
and if takes takes takes tonight isn't
occurring me not sneaky what to do three
then the 50x I take on e4 then I'll take
back with check
I think it's a winning but some time
situations rough well that's just
winning Wow
I'm eating let's go Wow I won this
despite my mouth slit which maybe it was
a good move you guys shouldn't complain
no that was a very short position um a
point was being really tricky where like
it looks like the bishops hanging that
if I take it there's my TC 6 with a
triple four with the pin along the D
file so workout for was a nice resource
rookie one again I'm like I really want
to take the bishop but again 96 and and
I guess put three III worked out really
well because I essentially crashed
through when White was still like under
attack and I think the rook and Bishop
apply a lot of pressure along with the
battery like the Queen checks always run
into King c7 where the Queen's attacks
so oh I see the clip Thanks right
whoever your name is so so this is what
happens I clicked the Queen and then I
think the Queen was highlighted so I
just clicked like a random square or no
wait what what happened there wait a
minute
so I click the Queen it happened really
quickly
oh I highly did the bishop and then I
tried to remove the highlight by
clicking a random square I guess the
Queen was still like it was still
selected so thankfully I clicked a
decent square
but that shouldn't it shouldn't happen
because I have my mood and move method
to dry pieces and not click okay it's
called clicks queries not click click
but there's this other thing only chess
where you can you can have drag click
click or both and a while ago I think it
defaults to both but a while ago I I had
to disable click click because it just
leads to too many mouths lips anyway
yeah I should we should ask about that
before my match but as long as I'm aware
of it I'll be more careful I think it
happens more when I'm like drawing
arrows and then now just click a square
to get rid of the arrows I guess I have
to be careful what Square I click evaded
so strong at least with chess maybe less
though with bundles Oh playing chess
Queen I play chess Queen before I've
said like she was I covered her games
and in st. Louis let's play London play
chess Queen a few times before in arena
Kings so she plays b6 go for this line
c4
actually played this kind of setup in
Speights my most recent match idea e6
okay so she plays g6
so I think I wanted to lay e3 wait what
oh she mouseland and she resigns oh
that's so sad
I feel so bad but that's part of that's
part of online chess I guess I I also
feel bad saying I feel bad while smiling
so many things to feel bad about what to
do I guess I get we all get like a long
break now can watch chess yeah I mean
yeah I now slip to the last game but it
was not on this level this is like a
lafon I wonder here sometimes you play a
move like this hoping your plummet pre
moves like if I cream of Queen c2 Bishop
h6 would have been genius anyway I can I
can maybe explain the move order in this
line there's different nuances analyze
a6 move game also shout out to chess
Queen she might be streaming she has a
lot of like great content very strong
player former former World Women's
Champion - yeah doing a lot on Twitch in
YouTube oops which I just do I just do
oh there we go okay so yeah so she
played b6 which usually signifies box
either going for double fianchetto or
going for kind of a Queen's in Union so
it's flexible move there's a line if if
black starts with e 6 and then plays d6
where's Queen f3 um which is actually a
Lila's choice I think sawfish is choice
2
but yeah b6 kind of avoids this Queen a
three-line so I played nine f3 and then
the main London move would be III but I
discovered the c4 move relatively
recently idea to be to delay III and the
vent that if black does play g6 the goal
is Knight c3 Queen c2 e4 and probably
what would have happened assuming she
plays Bishop g7 is Queen c2 and then
it's kind of hard for a lot to sati for
I think this should be computer approved
to again sawfish not working so can't
check the stock fish but anyway that's
this one small opening lesson if black
were to play e6 here then I would play
this and then I played some of these
structures in my my match against pates
where yeah there should be four Knights
f d2 is a interesting move where then
other night comes to c3 there's Queen c2
there's ideas of castling queenside in
some lines
anyway what's watching him it's chill
well let's watch naka where's naka or
lesson we can watch let's watch na kiss
playing doogie interesting do you ever
give take-backs
sometimes yeah I don't think I only take
backs are allowed in title Tuesday so
yeah what to do and take backs are not
allowed in my in the speech chess
championship either it's like one of
those things which is just part of
online chess Oh am I putting you just
sleep hope you you rest well
Joe Rogan puts you to sleep too it's
interesting
so many things to look at between the
scheme so many things in the chat is
there an audio delay as my voice
synchronized with my my mouth
hopefully it is in real life hey I'm
blur baby
thanks for something with which crime
[Music]
you try to mate stop fish level one with
nine Queens I know you did it against
Komodo can you do drop fish I was gonna
say just watch the Komodo challenge
video I could try but not right now
remind me later I don't know if you can
play sock fish on on chest column I
think it's just Komodo and there's 20
levels of Komodo Wong on chess calm me
Ches I can try and challenge soccer fish
level one I played soccer level one in
bullets family hyper bullet ultra
bullets that was a few months ago I just
completely destroyed me at least most
games naka just destroying yeah Wow what
did not go play onaka yeah this is not
cos like dumb blitz opening which is
actually kind of reasonable for blitz
and ih4 interesting just getting the
bishop hair Wow some interesting opening
he put he pushed so many pawns
developing or before developing his
pieces probably not the greatest role
model for for humor players I guess he
can get away with it yeah he had some
nice center center space
actually I I recently went back to
editing some of this the stockfish match
I played maybe I'll share later I made
like song I don't usually do like too
much intensive editing on my videos but
I did kind of make a compilation of a
bunch of it's upsetting moments well
I'll hold off on sharing yeah this is
definitely one of my best title
Tuesday's ever six out of nine or no six
out of eight with one round to go I'm
not in contention for a really top spot
but maybe I'm in contention for I don't
know something maybe I'll oh I won't
play NACA is he he's still a point above
me a uh shoe gifting a sub to to gaya
thanks so much boshy I'm hoping to play
a strong player be nice to play like a
super GM let's watch a limb ooh this is
a draw in six and a half so he'll have
seven on eight yeah just a draw looking
for players I know three chords playing
Mayer let's watch Mayer ooh what is this
position block was about wait oh yeah
this is just losing for blackbuck wasn't
so drunk if a King f8 makes maybe some
more sense but then King g6 in the king
wall run towards the pawns it's always
vidit playing look at the standings
the standings won't update until all the
games are done I think Robert Haas is
playing
hmm
okay let's watch the the GM who so games
are just finishing watch this game and
then I'm on verse FM looks like a draw
o'clock wants to win if the Queen were
ever to block on f6 and white takes the
pawn and fair results Johanna Maya and
the Maya
beat me is it on Amaya I think it's on
Amaya not on Imagi
she's probably streaming she beat me in
a recent title Tuesday she destroyed my
luncheon it was so sad and she's winning
this game very simple how hundred nine
moves I'm not gonna be playing I'm not
gonna be playing Stafford gambit in this
tournament
it's too risky especially against really
strong players there are times where
I'll play it though more so in bowling
okay playing another strong player final
game let's go opponents perplexed what's
going on only giving me time odds
okay so we have d4 ooh we might see Java
London
yeah doable London this is my new six
idea Bishop b4 ah
so might be five I think I have to play
96 here
okay I'm not remembering this
unfortunately but maybe Queen a5 as if
it should be maybe there should be for
first now it's probably more prepared
than I am
some a5 move if I'd Bishop a6 ideas
that's castle I probably want to bring
the bishop back to to d6 let the bishop
here
double-a pons don't look so so pretty if
I get the chance I would love to play c5
maybe 97 c5 white maybe wants to play c4
you rook c8 makes sense to start with
like this move and why not
now 97 a slightly strange position I
have the bishop here now c5 makes a lot
of sense
oh there's Bishop d6 Bishop d6 rook e8 I
was enough supporters on c5 I think my
problem is my C pawns pinned those
bishops not defended know what my thread
is maybe there should be five also not
sure what's gonna do here also bishop
before can be a move but then c3 and
takes nevermind let's stick with bishop
yeah we're just trading everything I
could take in Queen c7 it's logical I'll
just play a major piece on game and rook
c8 coming
I can take does this just went up on if
work too exciting just win that now I
have a five looks weakening them but
pawns upon my structure is not so pretty
there's a five here a for try for trying
to damage white structure maybe takes on
an 8 a 5 a 4 again
so I could and take and rook b8 be fine
that's a bit misplaced try this as we're
gonna see 5mm it's doing something
h5 is logical maybe a four takes rook
see to coming Oh Queen d7 is coming you
have F 4 here
not sure though
let's try it here
this couldn't fizzle out into a draw and
defending the pawn yeah cuz Queen d7 we
trade we got seven then we were the
repeats know if there's anything better
there it doesn't want to draw wait what
do I just take takes takes oh wait no I
can't take Wow
almost dropped a queen okay I have a
trick if g3 iff or I have g3 III its
tactics also they're just threatening e3
of Queen B too scary
Queen d2 doesn't threaten anything
let's throw this I want to play you
three not much time left
that was just bad this movie though
turning this
not good I'm almost on time I think I'm
in time no I missed this remove uh no
I'm gonna get tortured it might be a
fortress though somehow draw
to survive for until move 123 know why
flange oh I forgot about my time no oh
that's so sad oh that was a cool game
too
good game it's still a decent resolve so
many sages sacking yeah so actually this
is this is a very tricky position I
think I only have a few seconds left
here I only have one move one one decent
move to play rook if you want and then
move my king and then it should just be
a draw so 609 not too bad that's a
slightly unfortunate finish but a lot of
good fights yeah is really smooth I saw
yeah I saw it right after I played it
like I can't move here because I know up
check I can't leave the King here here
cuz promotes with discovered check so I
have to check first got the rock off the
the six rink and then move up earlier
really I was probably better to around
this position it's so complicated though
I really wanted to play III the problem
is my queen is tied down and then I
can't allow this
and then the nav there is some fortress
table-based women f4 is a good move
though I think this is lost because at
some points
I'm I'm Justin zooms long maybe I could
have played rock h4 though you know in
here if I could play rook h4 and just
you know see how light breaks through I
can't even imagine those legs along
there cuz my route can always always has
a square in like my kina is always
defending the pawn although it's just
like I'm have table these live analysis
Explorer maybe I don't know
congratulations to the winners oh this
core of off this looks like horrible
yeah anton carve off won the tournament
eating have fun 9 while angry twin who
is this dry gala
never heard of him and yeah his
grandmasters from russia are good at
blitz anyway that was yeah that was a
fun tournament so like i was in decent
form